Stacy and Jim Chapin remember their son
Ethan one of four University of Idaho
students murdered almost six months ago
he touched more lives in his 20 years
then most people may be touching a
lifetime he was kind he was inclusive
everybody was welcome that welcoming
presence led to lifelong friendships at
tulip Valley Farms where he worked along
with his brother and sister Hunter and
Maisie his friends decided to honor
Ethan's memory by creating a tulip mix
in his name they called it Ethan's smile
the white reminds us of his teeth and
the smile and the yellow is bright and
cheery and means friendship soon the
cheap and say it seemed many Touched by
Ethan's story okay wanted Ethan's smile
the Tulips just became this tangible
thing that literally the nation kind of
grabbed onto and so we've gone from
there and created a foundation